now first let's get right to our top
story lieutenant general michael flynn
is has always been an innocent man and
now it is more clear than ever
that a few corrupt high-ranking deep
state bureaucrats set him up
they were all bragging about it and
tonight all signs
point to the corrupt so-called
leadership of a higher calling honor
mr super patriot jim comey why because
according to newly unredacted fbi
documents just released today
in early january 2017 the fbi
the bureau determined that flynn was
quote no longer a viable candidate
as part of crossfire hurricane there was
no collusion
he did nothing wrong these documents
report that there was
no derogatory material on flynn in the
fbi files
no derogatory material in the defense
intel agency files
no derogatory material in the cia files
and by january 4th the case against
flynn they said it was
going to be dropped that is until the
corrupt
upper echelon of the fbi already
involved in
crossfire hurricane they jumped in peter
strzok we now know
sent several urgent texts demanding to
know if this case is still open
to his relief the case was never
officially closed even though they had
closed it
strzok texted quote amazing okay good
it's still open
and quote yeah our utter incompetence
actually helps us
wow that's breathtaking strzok informed
his colleagues at the seventh floor
now what's the seventh floor that's
where the fbi upper echelon leadership
is was involved and just like that a few
corrupt agents
they did in fact conspire they set flynn
up all
under the watch of james comey on
january 24
2017 one agent asked quote what is our
goal
is it truth is it admission or is our
goal to get him to lie
so that we could prosecute him or at
least get him fired
that is not a question that should ever
be asked by anyone any professional
and would never be asked by the 99
percent of brave professionals in the
fbi
now shouldn't the goal of the fbi not
that question
should it always be truth the rule of
law
justice they work in the department of
justice
we have a system of justice in america
apparently not in jim comey's fbi
look at this according to america's
number one super patriot
setting a perjury trap put this in
context
context for an american war hero 33
years of service under his belt for this
country
so we could all live free yeah that
would be important in one
unredacted note agents even considered
using
the logan act as a centerpiece of their
scheme
nobody ever has ever been found guilty
of violating this arcane law since it
was passed
in 1799 not one person even bloomberg
pointed out
yeah this very fact nope the logan act
been used repeatedly as a partisan
cajul to harass political opponents for
more than two american centuries
and what exactly happened well january
24th
that would be four days after donald
trump was inaugurated
mr hire loyalty super patriot jim comey
directed agents
to literally go in and ambush a 33-year
war vet
at the white house just four days after
trump's inauguration
and after deputy director mccabe of the
fbi
said to flynn oh you don't need a lawyer
then this isn't about you
not at all and since the white house was
in the middle of
chaos it's always chaotic during a
transition this is day four
comey saw a perfect opportunity to lay
his trap
you don't have to take my word for it
we've got james comey on tape kind of
like quid pro quojo
he's bragging about the setup that he'd
never do
in the bush or obama administrations or
ever get away with because there's a
process that he decided
well not to use take a look you look at
this white house now and it's hard to
imagine two fbi agents ending up in the
same room how did that happen
i sent them
something we i probably wouldn't have
done or maybe gotten away with
in a more organized investigation a more
organized administration
in the george w bush administration for
example or the obama administration
and in both of those administrations
there was process and so if the fbi
wanted to send agents into the white
house itself
to interview a senior official you would
work through the white house council and
there'd be discussions and approvals and
who would be there
and i thought it's early enough let's
just send a couple guys over
i sent them i took advantage of i said a
couple of guys up there something i'd
never do or get away with in the bush or
obama administrations
yeah i sent them wow following comey's
ambush the investigators involved
did not believe that flynn was lying how
do you like that but after multiple
major revisions of interrogation and
notes
by peter strzok lisa page viola
whom the fbi was able to charge flynn
with a crime
that he didn't commit that they didn't
think he committed and they threatened
his son
i don't know how good a father that
lieutenant general flynn is
he decided are you going to turn on my
son
unless i sign this lie i guess i have to
i have to fall on the sword for my son
wow what father wouldn't what good
father wouldn't but not before they
turned the screws they threatened flynn
behind to throw behind bars threatened
his son and his family
he had mounting legal bills oh he's
broke after 33 years of service the
lieutenant general
yep he was bankrupt he lost his house
his reputation in ruins all because of
comey
his corrupt agents at the very top of
the fbi they all hated trump they've
been involved in stopping
getting elected and then sabotaging him
ever since
spying on him in the words of attorney
general barr deep into the trump
presidency
now this is why i make a distinction you
know this pin is
the fbi pin in solidarity for the 99
percent of our federal and state law
enforcement officials
they say serve us bravely and with honor
and with integrity the best of the best
but the malignant agenda-driven one
percent
uh they're now threatening the very
basis of our justice system
they must be held accountable and to the
credit of this attorney general
he is doing just that he's following
justice in the rule of law
equal application of the law equal
justice under the law
they ruined the life of an american war
hero they spied on carter page they
ruined his life
by the way then they used a fisa
application a warrant
that was based let's see hillary
clinton's bought and paid for
dirty dossier full of russian
disinformation that
russia even the new york toilet times
gets this
clearly used to help clinton and
mess with our elections yeah russian
disinformation to steal the hillary's
paying for
that is unverifiable because it's
debunked devin nunes he warned the
entire country in 2014
that the hostile regime in russia and
the hostile actor putin
would do this biden obama the compromise
corrupt congenital liar shift they did
nothing to stop
it they spied on the trump campaign the
trump transition team
and even as the ag pointed out as i said
deep into the trump presidency
in other words they laid a perjury trap
in this case
they set a perjury trap for george
papadopoulos they knocked down paul
manafort's door that case was dead and
buried they
dragged it out of mothballs just to hurt
trump they well raided his home in the
middle of the night
guns drawn scaring the crap out of him
and his wife
and tax fraud charges and they sent
dozens of agents
oh 30 of them tactical gear to surround
the home of roger stone at 3 a.m
for a process crime that the inspector
general
suspects that comey and mccain
themselves are guilty of
anyway they raided the house 3am
roger stone invited cnn to film it all i
guess they just happened to be bored
that night just happened to be in the
right place at the right time right
because he allegedly lied to congress uh
usually what they say is can you report
at
8 00 a.m that would be the way you
handle that but not if you're abusing
power
so what is the common denominator in all
this it is president trump they were
determined to take down this
administration this president one way or
another and today the president had this
to say about the corrupt agents
in the deep state and their cheerleaders
in the mob which is 99 percent of the
media today
take a look i really hoped because
cnn tormented him in all fairness i
really hope to see because they haven't
been doing it
and i appreciate your question i hope to
see that cnn
will not even apologize which they
should
but just cover it fairly because he's in
the process
of being exonerated if you look at those
notes from yesterday
that was total exoneration these were
dirty filthy cops at the top of the fbi
president has been right we've been
right the program here we've reported
the truth about this abuse of power and
corruption
and frankly for three plus years it's
been a little bit of a lonely road they
were pushing their conspiracy theories
and their smears and lies and slander
for almost all media outlets including
socialist state tv
msdnc fake news cnn toilet paper of
record the new york toilet paper times
instead of holding our federal
government accountable
they were cheering for the demise of an
american war hero and wanting to take
out a duly elected president
they didn't want him elected take a look
did flynn go rogue by the way when he
spoke to russia
well that would be a bigger scandal than
almost
anything we've ever seen in any other
presidential administration
next we're gonna get back to michael
flynn's guilty plea today and what
that's
well how it's made this a historic day
here in d.c the fact is
michael flynn betrayed his country
the warrant application was a warrant
based on probable cause not proof
that he was a foreign agent a judge
today all but called him a traitor
the president today wished him well
after two hours of a judge
rebuking fired national security adviser
michael flynn using words such as
treason and disgust and disdain
you think any of these outlets have the
honor decency concern for truth and
justice and integrity to say to general
flynn
we're sorry don't hold your breath
bureaucrats
tremendous power you have the mob
tremendous power
ruining the lives of innocent americans
yep
trying to influence an election trying
to unseat a duly elected president of we
smelly walmart chopper guns bible
believing god people
irredeemable deplorables trump
transition team
and trump presidency and the mob they
helped him every step of the way
sickening journalism's dead i've told
you it's dead
but we will continue to demand justice
we will continue to go
our own way forge our own path on this
show
we have been unrelenting for three years
and we're not stopping
justice fairness freedom the fabric of
our republic means something to
us and soon thanks to the attorney
general kudos to bill barr
what did he do his job that's what his
job is
follow the law he's doing it durham
apparently doing it also
justice is coming for all who abuse
their power
tonight president trump just wrapped up
another
massive rally yup the rallies are back
look at this video from dan scavino
do you think the biden campaign could
ever get
crowds this size just you keep watching
and keep looking at the video look at it
because
what you see that's the overflow crowd
those are the people that didn't fit
inside the massive
rally space the inside part in freeland
michigan tonight
supporters lining up around the block
and down the street we'll show it all
we've got plenty of time
according to reports some were waiting
in line for more than
24 hours we've got the highlights
president was on fire tonight along with
also tonight a full report our 2020
election correspondent lawrence jones
he is on the ground he was at the rally
tonight
also we're going to bring you breaking
news from the dorm pro
this is huge mueller's team led by of
course
his well hit man andrew weissman the
pitbull
caught in a massive cover-up just like
hillary clinton almost
all of them guess what they wiped their
phones
clean is that obstruction of justice by
team mueller we'll investigate
and are more charges on the way but
first we start with another blatant lie
from the ever forgetful joe biden now
joe actually wants americans you the
american people to believe that
he can beat covet 19 but only if you
elect him
if he remembers what it is in november
december january
he claims he sounded the alarm early on
about the deadly virus and that
president trump did everything wrong
okay joe's lying just like his friends
in the media mob
and well most liberal democrats these
days joe biden
is living an alternative reality once
again
here are the facts that the hey trump
media mob will never give you will do
their job for them
in late january just days before the
president issued
what was the unprecedented china travel
ban
and first quarantined in 50 years 10
days
after the first identified case in this
country well
biden's top advisor his name is ron
klein
he was actually praising china's
transparency
huh watch this i think what you have to
say about china is
it's been more transparent and more
candid than it has been during past
outbreaks
though still there are problems with
transparency and candor
okay remember so it's the same china
where zero experience
hunter biden got the sweetheart 1.5
billion deal from the bank of china you
know not deutsche bank not goldman sachs
uh not chase uh no that would be
joe biden hunter his son quid pro quo
joe sucking up to hunter he's
compromised by china
peter schweitzer has identified this in
detail
and so on january 28th three days before
the president's travel ban just seven
days after the first identified case
this same biden health advisor said that
he opposed the travel ban
it was premature but they were on top of
it that's what they said watch
would you ban chinese travelers from
arriving in the united states
i wouldn't i think that's premature i
think it's very important
exchange very important for trade and
tourism and the very very few of those
people will have it what's more
uh you know since this virus broke out a
quarter million people have come from
china so they're already here
and then one day before the president's
travel ban january 30th
top biden health official dr zeke
emanuel said
everyone needed to stop panicking stop
being hysterical
then on february 1st that's the day that
biden day after the travel ban was
implemented
after 10 days the first identified case
of corona
well joe himself tweeted out that the
travel ban was hysterical xenophobia and
fear-mongering
on february 13 topped by an advisor
claimed he tweeted that
we are experiencing a fear epidemic not
a coveted 19 epidemic
joe biden himself called the president's
aggressive coven 19 response
the travel ban the first quarantine in
over 50 years
hysterical xenophobia fear mongering
on multiple occasions as late as march
the 18th
and meanwhile joe biden was still
holding indoor rallies in the month of
march and
he was doling out his world famous
creepy hugs remember those
he wasn't talking about social
distancing he wasn't wearing a mask he
wasn't coordinating an aggressive
use of the defense production act plan
or sourcing
ppe and he was against the travel ban
against the quarantine against the
subsequent travel ban
now that likely saved at least hundreds
and hundreds of thousands of americans
from contracting the virus and god knows
how many thousands of americans
from dying and by the way he didn't get
to that until
april get this biden's press secretary
now
like biden blatantly lying and
pretending
that the ever forgetful joe was always
in favor of the travel ban
that's called the lie the ban that they
called
joe multiple times including late march
hysterical xenophobic fear-mongering
take a look
you're saying that joe biden was for
closing down travel from china when the
president did it
uh joe biden has been clear and i can
send you the fact checks if they're
helpful
brad joe biden has been clear that he
was not against that travel ban but he
was for it
joe biden has been clear about this
brett again i can send i can send you
the fact checks
if they're helpful this has been fact
checked into oblivion okay i'm just
asking you the question
you're saying yes he was for the china
travel ban when the president
implemented it two 48 hours after
receiving that briefing
the important thing about the travel ban
yes no yes and i know
brett i know that you all like to cite
the travel brand i know that no no the
president does that's why i'm bringing
it up
obviously it's going to be in the debate
brett hold on the important thing to
know about the travel ban
is that even after the president
implemented that travel ban
tens or says that he implemented it tens
of thousands of people
came in and out of i'm gonna take it
that you're not gonna answer that
question you're gonna send me some fact
checks
rep bear has the patience of job there
because he's lying
and everybody knows it in other words
joe biden did everything wrong
but now he's going to lie about it and
hope that you will all
forget what really happened you know i
love the woodward hysteria you know
about bob woodward's book
yeah uh the president said he wanted to
calm fears in america
what do we have to fear but fear itself
fdr said at the height of
the great depression world war ii
remember those tough days
churchill you know the bombing of
britain out marching with the people of
britain
was he talking well get them in the
hills and everywhere blood tile tears
and sweat
that's what leaders do biden is saying
no this is hysterical xenophobia fear
mongering
he offered no solutions nothing new for
biden
and his team to lie by the way imagine
if prep bear was actually questioning
joe biden there
that would be that would be tv
pay-per-view from deep funding to police
he lies about that
reallocation he calls it uh uh
fracking oh against it against it but no
i was always for it
protests oh yeah no they're peaceful
until well
it's showing up badly in the polls
national mass mandate
well joe biden said oh no i don't want
that either
okay he lies about pretty much every
position he's ever taken
only if it helps him politically only if
the polls and focus groups tell him what
to say like
don lemon advised him to listen to but
here's what's more concerning
joe biden is actually really
weak and frail and doesn't seem mentally
alert or on top of his game doesn't seem
to have a lot of
well let's say mental acuity just listen
to biden's top advisor
the guy you just heard from ron klain
saying that the biden obama response
listen to what they admitted about their
response to the h1n1 virus not the n1 h1
virus as biden calls it take a look
i wasn't involved directly in the h1n1
response but i i lived through it as a
white house staffer
and what i will say about it is a bunch
of really talented really great people
working on it and we did every possible
thing wrong
and it's you know 60 million americans
got h1n1
uh in that period of time and it's just
purely a fortuity that this isn't one of
the great mass casualty events in
american history
had nothing to do with us doing anything
right just had to do with luck
they did everything wrong then they
didn't prepare for the next
real pandemic make no mistake 50 years
in the swamp
joe biden is now more incompetent than
ever nobody our own lawrence jones 2020
correspondent on the ground that he's
ever interviewed
has been able to identify a single
accomplishment in 50 years of joe biden
in the swamp
that has made life better for you the
american people
i could spend the entire show talking
about donald trump's promises made
promises kept
and records shattered especially on the
issue of unemployment
and building the wall and originalists
on the supreme court
new trade deals and pulling out a
protracted wars and defeating the
caliphate solimani al-baghdadi and
associates
and al-qaeda leaders all over the world
biden light again this week has said
over
nearly 6 200 u.s military members died
from corona
well he's wrong again well there have
been exactly
seven military deaths from covet 19 not
nearly 6 200.
without a teleprompter the ever
forgetful joe can barely communicate
today president trump had a few
observations about
biden's well precious teleprompter take
a look at this
as we continue to follow the
science-based approach to
protect our people and vanquish the
virus joe biden continues to use the
pandemic
for political gain every time i see him
he starts talking about their pandemic
he's reading it off a teleprompter i'm
not allowed to use a teleprompter why is
that phil
they ask questions and he starts reading
the teleprompter
he says move the teleprompter a little
bit closer please
i don't know i think if i did that i'd
be in big trouble i think that would be
that would be the story of the year a
teleprompter can you can you can you
move it down
the teleport move i have to read the
answer
president is right and get this
apparently biden's teleprompters not
just for speeches
because it looks an awful like like he's
using
it to answer supposedly unscripted
questions
just listen to biden's press secretary
from earlier today this is another great
moment
has joe biden ever used a teleprompter
during local interviews
or to answer q a with supporters brett
we are not going to engage this is
this is straight from the trump campaign
exactly they're using it and what it
does
and what it does brett is it's trying to
distract the american people i'm just
they're using it they talk about it
every day can you say yes or no that's
because they talk about it every day
right because they don't have
a coherence well you have an answer yes
or no
brett they talk about it every day
because they don't have a coherent
argument for why donald trump deserves
re-election
but you can't answer the question right
i am not going to allow
trump campaign to funnel their questions
through fox news and get me to respond
to that
does he use the teleprompter to answer a
question
yes or no simple question that's what
you call an evasive non-answer
because he'd have to lie again i think
we all know why his campaign is trying
to limit
his extemporaneous comments just look at
what happened wednesday
joe had to go off script a little
troubling
i want to thank you all i carry with me
i don't have it i gave gave it to my
staff but i carry with me
in my pocket hey do i have that
around anyone where's my staff
i gave it away anyway i carry a schedule
in my pocket
hold these truths to be self-evident old
man created equal and doubt by
the the thing thing you know
come on man come on you a junkie
okay gets worse at a different event
wednesday biden couldn't even remember
what taxes he wants to raise we know
it's trillions but he doesn't remember
which ones whatever they get
put in front of me i'll sign it take a
look
if you change the tax rate it went from
38 percent to 21.
you just send it back to 20 over 38
percent
that's what we started to try to do he
went down to 21.
truth is we have an information crisis
in the country this is serious we don't
have any real journalists at fake news
cnn
msdnc any of the newspapers
networks abc nbc nbc state run
democratic socialist tv biden's constant
struggles if it was donald trump i
promise it would be a huge story
instead washington post more focused on
praising
kamala harris on her shoe choice very
important story
meanwhile major networks devoted 16
minutes to smearing president trump
guess how many minutes they devoted to
his nobel peace prize nomination
zero and while the mob and the media
they're doing whatever they can do to
prop up the ever forgetful joe president
trump
he's on fire he's on offense tonight he
did something
joe biden simply cannot do actually
hold a real rally deliver a long
forceful speech in front of a massive
crowd let's
dip in and take a look this is the most
important election in the history of our
country
joe biden devoted his career to
offshoring michigan's jobs
outsourcing biden supported every
disastrous globalist sellout
for over a half a century including
nafta
china and tpp you know that
joe biden surrendered your jobs to china
and now he wants to surrender our
country to the
violent left-wing mob and you're seeing
that every night
[Applause]
if biden wins china wins if biden wins
the mob
wins if biden wins the rioters anarchist
arsonists
and flag burners win
[Applause]
but i wouldn't worry about it because
he's not winning i don't think
it's all on the ballot you're the
ultimate jury in 24 days
oh biden's holding virtual q a sessions
on instagram
only problem biden never actually
answered any questions per usual
last night near the end of the debate
something remarkable happened
joe biden for the first time all night
actually told the truth about something
take a look
i have one final would he close down the
airline if it falls
or would you close down the earth i have
a transition from the oil industry yes
oh transition it is a big statement
because
i would stop why would you do that
because the oil industry
pollutes significantly i said here's the
deal but
that's a big step well if you let me
finish the statement
because it has to be replaced by
renewable energy
over time he finally said it under a
biden harris administration the oil and
gas
industry would become a thing of the
past now
oil gas fossil fuel fuels
happen to be the lifeblood of the
world's economy
and by the way millions of high-paying
career jobs in america would be
eliminated
and of course thanks to president trump
in the last three and a half years
we have now become energy independent
for the first time in 75 years
we are now for the first time in more
than 75 years
the world's largest producer of energy
and if joe biden
well if he becomes president that all
goes away
so if you live in pennsylvania ohio
texas oklahoma be prepared to suffer
because if joe biden gets his way
hundreds of thousands of high-paying
jobs
in pennsylvania alone will be gone
nationwide well over 10 million jobs
will
be eliminated and the industries that
benefit from the energy sector
well they'll lose jobs as well now
that's from anywhere between
six and ten percent of the entire u.s
workforce
manufacturing costs will skyrocket in
this country
that means manufacturing will once again
go overseas
energy costs will skyrocket for every
american family
america's economy would ultimately be
destroyed even before
biden's proposed tax increases on the
middle class and small business
and in the process america's adversaries
like russia china venezuela
they would then own the oil and gas
industry
that would allow them to become more
powerful
than ever before that will weaken our
national security and joe will be making
russia china venezuela and the middle
east
a lot of countries that don't like us
there he'll be making
their economies great again instead of
making
america's economy great again now the
biden plan to quote transition from oil
and gas
is so insane that even some democrats
today in swing districts
they are racing for cover you know some
of biden's fellow democrats are even
publicly rebuking
his extreme agenda and by the way now
joe and kamala harris they're doing
their best and have been
all day at damage control they're now
pretending that he doesn't really want
to ban oil and gas
in other words they're just lying now
the green new deal
which they both support which calls for
the abolition
of fossil fuel is literally endorsed
it's right there on joe biden's own
website
and joe and kamala harris think that we
the american people
we must be stupid and by the way that
they can just lie to our faces over and
over and over again
and think we're going to forget that
many times they said they would ban
fracking and eliminate fossil fuels last
night's debate was no exception
for example joe biden said that no one
lost
their insurance under obamacare well
millions lost their plans
millions lost their doctors and on
average were paying
about 200 percent more when they say
said we've saved 2500
per family per year joe also said he
never opposed the president's china
travel ban that was another lie too joe
actually repeatedly called the travel
ban xenophobic
hysterical fear-mongering he did it the
day after the president
implemented the travel ban from china
that was only 10 days after the first
identified case of coronavirus
and he was doing it in late march at one
point joe
also said that he never opposed fracking
this lie was so egregious even fake news
cnn
they had to fact check it so joe do you
realize
how stupid and dishonest and sleazy
you look by doing this take a look would
there be
any place for fossil fuels including
coal
and fracking in a biden administration
no
we would we would work it out we would
make sure it's eliminated and no more
subsidies for either one of those
i guarantee you i guarantee you
we're gonna end fossil fuel there's no
question i'm in favor of banning
fracking
i'd gradually move away from frackies i
think it's critically important on day
one
that we end any fossil fuel leases on
public lands
no more no new fracking
eliminate fracking he said it eliminate
fracking pennsylvania
which joe do you believe the president
he was right
47 years in the swamp joe biden all
talk no action and whenever he does do
something
it usually means that we the american
people pay a heavy price
and sadly biden's blatant dishonesty
didn't end there
he also told this incredibly bizarre lie
about the united states
and adolf hitler take a look you know
what north korea
we're not in a war we have a good
relationship you know people don't
understand
having a good relationship with leaders
of other countries
we have a lot of questions to get to
that's right and we had a good
relationship with
hitler before he in fact invaded europe
the rest of europe come on come on man
the u.s was sending weapons joe and
other
supplies across the atlantic to hitler's
adversaries well before the war maybe
something tells me that joe
was not a very good student oh that's
right too because he finished
near the bottom of his law school class
and then he lied about that like he's
lied about so many other things like
being
endorsed by the naacp that was a lie
now that is actually what sank his first
presidential bid just a few decades ago
you get the theme here joe biden told
many lies last night
at one point president trump forcefully
you know brought the issue of the kids
and the cages smeared that the democrats
are too fond of
yeah and told the truth take a look
they built cages you know they used to
say i built the cages
and then they had a picture in a certain
newspaper
and it was a picture of these horrible
cages and they said look at these cages
president trump built them and then it
was determined they were built
in 2014. that was him they did it
we just did not they built the cages
they who built the cages
let's talk about who built the cages by
the way
joe you see those cages these pictures
yeah you built that i know obama's fond
of saying
you didn't build that but you guys did
build that you put the kids in cages
and these pictures are from the time
that you
were vice president and barack obama was
president
now it was president trump who reformed
america's child
immigration practices not you in nearly
50 years in the d.c
swamp joe has said a lot of things made
a lot of promises
has very little to nothing to show for
his efforts last night president trump
held biden's fee to the fire take a look
i don't make money from china you do i
don't make money from ukraine
you do i don't make money from russia
you made three and a half million
dollars joe i ran because of you
i ran because of barack obama because
you did a poor job
if i thought you did a good job i would
have never run that's a technical
political statement
let's get off this china thing and then
he looks the family around the table
everything
just a typical politician when i see
that let's talk about not a difficult
politician okay that's why i got elected
all night joe is struggling to defend
himself frequently instead of
making cogent points or rebuttals
joe reverted back to his favorite go-to
line
come on man come on man are you a are
you a junkie
that was one of my favorites anyway he
did it numerous times throughout the
night and throughout the campaign take a
look
why the hell would i take a test come on
man
come on it's like saying you before you
got in this program if you take a test
where you're taking cocaine or not what
do you think huh
are you a joke come on if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or
trump and you ain't black so don't worry
about it
come on i got votes for that bill
i convinced people to vote for it
radical left
will you listen come on you have been no
caucus
no you haven't you're a lion dog face
pony soldier come on
and you want to check my shape on let's
do push-ups together man let's do let's
run let's do whatever you want to do
come on now joe should have been rested
because he spent five of the last six
days inside his basement bunker just
preparing for the debate
taking naps and drinking hot cocoa is
that the best you got
come on come on man come on man anyway
in joe's defense
it was way past his bedtime that's
probably why i was looking at his
watch likely hoping and praying that the
debate would soon come to a
merciful end you might remember during
the 1992 debate with george herbert
walker bush
he looked at his watch oh became a
national scandal in fact decades later
the media mob was still
obsessing and reminiscing about the
scandalous watch moment
they're eerily quiet about joe though
take a look
in 1992 george h.w bush deliberately
looks at his watch and he pays for it
when the audience and voters
see it as disrespectful george bush is
caught in the background looking at his
watch and he doesn't just glance at his
watch he does it like he's in a theater
production and trying to make sure they
see it in the last row
and it just accentuated this this
pre-existing narrative that george w
bush was
just kind of not in the moment wanted to
get through this thing
didn't care all right so i wonder if
biden will receive the same treatment
from the media mob
of course not last night many praised
the debate moderators quote even-handed
performance
i didn't think it was so even-handed she
interrupted president trump
uh nearly 30 times and interrupted biden
only twice
as we've been telling you there are
powerful institutional forces including
the media mob
big tech social media democratic
socialists
so-called never trumpers weak
establishment republicans and of course
the deep state
all aligned against this president the
only thing that can stop them in 11 days
is
you the american people you're the
ultimate jury
now even so it's joe biden not president
trump who
is resting at his home in delaware
tonight despite an unprecedented
leisurely campaign schedule i guess joe
is exhausted
now this is important if joe biden
doesn't have the strength the stamina
the mental acuity the mental alertness
to handle
the rigors of a campaign how does he
plan to lead the free world considering
that's
the hottest hardest job in the world